I am not here to
entertain you today.
I don't have the capacity
to do that right now.
I am here as one regular
human being to another
because I am not
happy right now.
I am not happy with myself,
and I need to talk to someone about it.
I just haven't been the
best version of myself recently.
I said that I had ambitions
to try and make films,
but I've been making incredibly
slow progress on the short film
that I've been trying to write over
the course of the last year.
In regards to my YouTube channel,
not only am I not posting content
as regularly as I want to,
and know that I can because
I've done it well enough in the past,
but I also don't think the stuff
I've been making recently is just
as good as it used to be,
and that just makes me really sad.
And the worst part of it for me is
that I am trying incredibly hard
to be the person
that I want to be again,
but every time I sit and stare
at that blank text file,
ready to try and come up
with something new,
I find myself
terrified to create.
Like genuinely scared.
And the thing that I'm scared of,
honestly, I think it's you.
I think I am scared
of you now,
and that's not good.
We need to fix that.
I realized this recently when I sat down to try
and work out why I do anything, really.
Why anybody does anything.
And the best answer I could come up
with is that every person, deep down,
whether they are
willing to admit it or not,
just-- they want other
people to like them,
and that's all it's
ever been for me.
Before YouTube, for me,
it was magic tricks.
I used to go around school
with a magnet up my sleeve,
and I would make coins
disappear out of people's hands.
And I did it because it impressed people,
and that made me feel cool.
And, given the incredibly shy kid
that I was back then,
was a huge deal
for me.
Then YouTube happened,
and I started to feel better about myself
than I ever have
in my entire life
because people liked
me all of a sudden,
more people than I could ever hope to
impress at school doing magic tricks,
and my confidence boosted to highs
that I had never experienced before.
But over the course
of the last year,
whatever confidence I had left is
dwindled away to practically nothing.
When I try and make stuff nowadays,
what holds me back isn't the idea
that maybe it's not going
to be very good,
It's maybe you won't like it
and then by extension you won't like me.
And so I run away, which is what
I like to do when I am scared.
I run and I don't do
anything at all,
and I really wish
that wasn't the truth
because I can't escape the idea
that me wanting other people to like me
is somehow weak and I should just
make whatever I want to make
and not care about what
anyone else thinks of me,
but I can't help but care
about what you think
because worrying what other people
think of me has been my whole life.
I spend almost everyday
being anxious
about what my peers
think of me, you know,
what are the conversations that they have
about me when I'm not in the room,
what are the flaws of mine
that they have noticed but
would never dare to
point out to me,
and do they even talk
about me at all is another one.
Like do they even care
enough to discuss me?
That's what the inside of
my brain looks like.
My hope is that this is just
what it's like to be human,
that everybody secretly
just feels the same way as me,
just as anxious as I do
about other people,
but I don't know
that for sure,
and I don't know what
to do about this either.
Like the simplest answer to me is that
I should just stop caring about it so much,
but I have no idea
how to do that.
All I want to do with my life
is make and do things
that make other
people happy.
I can't think of a better way to
spend my time on this planet,
but right now I just
have to hope, I guess,
that I have the capacity within myself
to be that person that I want to be
because right now,
I just don't know.
I am unsure.
And that scares
me a lot.
If you have been, thank you for sticking
with me over the course of this last year.
I really appreciate it more
than anything else, truly.
And thank you for
listening to me. Bye.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.